[Music]
my name is mark grover i'm a product
manager at lyft
uh and with me is alyssa and we're going
to talk to you
um today about a month in the data
discovery engine so i've i've worked on
a bunch of open source projects in the
past mostly helping
organizations uh build more data and
uh that that uh only cause a little bit
of chaos when it comes to using data and
that's where
that's what led to this project alyssa
do you want to introduce yourself
yeah so i'm currently on the security
team at square mostly dealing with
data privacy um i've been leading on and
supporting a lot of privacy engineering
efforts across dozens of teams at square
cool so we can start with like what was
the problem here the first problem that
uh we encountered at lyft was that we
noticed that if you look at a data
scientist
workflow or an analyst's workflow it
involves some sort of discovery of like
what features or what data sets am i
going to use then some exploration or
descriptive statistics to understand
the those data sets
build some trust around them then
there's actual work that they get paid
for and then some communication
and visualization but
one thing that was surprising to me was
that over 25 percent
of the time was in discovery and over
ten percent of the time was an
exploration which meant that over a
third of their time was spent
in quote unquote busy work that if you
could reduce that time they could
actually work on
other interesting stuff that only they
could do right but
the other side effects where it leads to
a very interrupt heavy culture i don't
know if
if you have this in your organizations
in mind for sure there was like
me me slacking pete and be like hey pete
do you know what
data set i should use for etas is that
trustworthy
and also there's like this increased
database load from queries that
you know people like me would write be
like oh select star from this table
limit 100 i just want to preview this
data right or
count star over the last seven days or
something like that and that was
a big part of the problem so what we're
trying to do is we're trying to reduce
these two steps and the time spent in
these two steps to be lower
and the requirements really came down to
grabbing
interesting metadata around our data and
exposing that to users so the first
question is what metadata makes sense
and this is a good paper from ground
that
uh helps structure that uh the first one
is application context which is like
where is this data what what does it
mean second one's behavior who's using
it who created it the third one is
change
how is this data evolving over time and
the the code that generated evolving
over time right
and you see that arrow on the right it
shows like where we are today i feel
that we do a fairly good job of
application context but uh
an okay job maybe starting to get in the
data behavior context and
absolutely nothing in the change context
right and about what data we want to do
it over
all our uh interesting data data assets
and the first one is obviously data
stores so your databases or s3
uh people are an important part right if
i know alyssa used this data set and
alyssa as a
is a great analyst then i would i would
trust to use the same data set too
and the this goes on and the line at the
bottom shows how far along we are so i
at least in the context of once and
we've done a pretty good job of data set
and people
were in the category of dashboards and
reports
and so what i'm going to show you today
is the example of the first application
we built on top of this metadata data
discovery and trust application
and the goal for this application was to
expose data in
metadata in opinionated ways around
searching for this metadata
being able to do lineage based analysis
on this
network based and programmatic so
searching is pretty obvious lineages
i want to see what are the upstream data
sets or what is the etl
that produce this data set network based
is oh alyssa is the team lead of the
team
i want to i want to follow her and see
what data sets does she commonly use
what data sets has she bookmarked
programmatic is a long slew of use cases
in fact the square use cases in this
category
where you have you just can't anticipate
all the applications and the ways you
would access the metadata so it's
important to have it programmatic
so what led um from this requirements
was a monsoon i'm skipping a bunch of
details around
the analysis of build versus buy we did
and if we have more time we can talk
about it in the
office ours too but the front page of
munch and this is like the pouring
aspect of the metadata
looks uh it's a search box and you can
bookmark things and there are some
some tags you can apply on it more
importantly has popular tables that are
determined based on
what else is being used in the
organization you can search for
something there's a
way for you to see the search results in
context but
when you click and by the way i should
say these search results are based on
two things they are matched against the
certain
attributes of the data set so the name
the
column names the table name the
descriptions of the tables and the
columns the tags you may have applied
but they are ranked based on query
activity so the data sets that are
heavily queried kind of like pagerank
show up higher in the results and data
sets that are less queried
once you go to the data set page you see
rich information about them so you see
that this data set is from hive it's
gold you can put badges on it so this
one has a badge of high quality or pii
you can put descriptions you have the
first rate
date and the last day for which there's
data frequent users
tags obviously this is a dummy example
in a real case you would have
uh you know not all frequent users
starting from the from the letter r
uh and then owners you have descriptions
and one thing i want to point out
is that there most of this metadata is
automatic right so i don't ask somebody
to put in when was the first date for
which this data exists
we decipher that through the metadata
and the data structures
you can click on a column and you see
stats of that column
so here you can see min max and so on
and so forth and i want to go back one
slide and show you that on the right
side you have
airflow and github so this shows you
airflow dag that populated this data set
that's linked to it
and the code that populated this data
set as well so that's where we get into
lineage when people talk about lineage
it means a few different things but
often they talk about data set to data
set lineage and often they talk about
app to data set lineage so in this case
these are two examples of app to data
set lineage
where airflow is the app and then github
is a source that was used in the app
you can see a preview of the data if you
have access and
that's by clicking the preview button
you can also search for dashboards so i
wanted to share a little more
about that so in this case you see the
dashboard page here
when was the dashboard created when it
was last updated um you have to and
again this is the
dashboard to table lineage so you see
the tables that are used in this
dashboard
and that and the queries that are used
in the dashboard i don't have a mod for
that and you can click on the dashboard
and uh and see it you see in the bottom
left a preview of the dashboard if you
have
access to it you can search for people
so here you see as
a person i'm showing you my page and it
shows what data sets i own what data
sets i bookmark and what data sets i
frequently use
impact so this has been a pretty solid
product at lyft
this is the graph up and to the right
and if you notice this is a
this is a graph where i say that
it's real because if you notice in
december 2019 there's a dip because
not many people were using data and it
has
months and today has over 700 weekly
active users
and a lot of employee pages here's a
list of
people who use the munson so you get a
lot of
so the blue bar is the number of such
people at the company and the red bar
is how many of them used it in the last
week
and you notice that the bar is obviously
the penetration rate among swedes is
fairly low and that's because the
general suite doesn't necessarily use
analytical data which is a problem
at large in the community but the data
engineers we
use this quite heavily the interesting
unsurprising part it's a data scientist
research scientist so people who
actually like
analyze and model data use this quite
heavily
and then there's a long tail off uh
perhaps more business roles like
economist customer quality
and special uh ops associates marketing
associates using this data
in terms of roadmap for this application
we want to actually have a tighter
lineage integration so right now we have
we delegate lineage to a separate
third-party app
we want to build and grab that lineage
for data sets
within the application integration of
views so you can see view definition in
there
acl integration so only allow specific
roles to edit descriptions
context of what was matched in the
search and obviously index more
resources
amundsen is also open source it has
around 700 community members
about 150 companies in the community and
more than 20 companies using in
production
and here's a sense of like who are the
prominent users
and and this is a good segue so
what we built to munson for was to
collect all this metadata from various
different sources in an automatic manner
and build the data discovery interest
application but what we are learning
is that other organizations square in
this example
is using the same metadata to build a
slightly complementary application that
of
security and access find access control
so alyssa is here to talk about
how they extended a monsoon to build
that second application of security in
acl
so as mark just said um i'm going to
talk now about one of the ways we're
using in lens next square
we're currently building on top of the
amundsen platform to support more
scalable automated data insights
for empowering and preserving our users
privacy by converting these insights
into more granular data access controls
and i'll go into more of what that means
in the next slides all right so before i
start i want to give you a better
understanding of the lenses architecture
so that the things i say later make more
sense
as you can see here it's the
microservices architecture
the data builder service ingests data
from multiple sources
uh examples here archive postgres
redshift presto
and that's where we also ingest data
from bigquery instead of like
the adjusted data that's stored in the
graph database um currently supports
atlas and neo4j
uh that's where we've actually been
building out support for grammarly and
supported databases
like neptune and janus graph which we're
going to contribute back soon to the
community
the data gets added into an elastic
search index uh so that your users on
the front end can more quickly search
for and
discover data and then when users on the
front end do things data gets pulled
either from the metadata service
graph database or from the search
service which is backed by elasticsearch
depending on what they're doing this is
sort of what the graph
or the data actually looks like in the
graph you can see that the ingested
schema information is
pulled out into nodes that point to each
other so
if we're querying details from this
graph it really only requires one search
one search operation to find the anchor
node and then traverse a specific path
through the data
and this makes the graph pretty
performant we don't need any joint
operations to find things other nice
thing about using the graph database
is that it's easily extensible so when
we want to add more metadata or
resources
um we can just essentially add another
node to the database so
v0 monson has supported tables and
associated metadata
as you saw in some of the slides that
mark just shared
lyft recently added support for
dashboards so as an example you can see
that when they added dashboards
it was relatively simple in terms of the
graph to just add a new dashboard graph
type here
or another type okay so with that
background in mind
uh let me come back around to our usb
set square so
remember that i'm on the privacy
engineering team which is part of our
security org
we care about making sure privacy is
both usable and scalable at square
so when i started at square we rely
mostly on manual
by individual teams to understand our
data but we have a lot of data
and it's only growing so we wanted to be
able to scale and automate insights into
the data that we stored collected and
processed
um this would allow us not only to
continue to meet legal requirements from
laws like gdpr and ccpa
but also aim for broader goals related
to privacy square
going back to this architecture diagram
i showed you before
we made a few updates to supporting uh
user privacy at scale so
first on this left-hand side we're using
a munson to store more specific metadata
about our data
that relates to our privacy and security
goals second in the data builder
arena we're automating data inventorying
where possible
i know that some companies have super
manual processes of looking at data and
trying to decide what information is
sensitive
so we're trying to reduce the amount of
manual work that's necessary for our
data owners
to reduce human error and make privacy
easier
um third we're building on the two
things i mentioned we're tightening our
access controls so that our
data users only have access to this and
the things that they need and nothing
more
all right so let's dig a little bit
deeper into how we're storing more
specific metadata in a munson
we actually introduced three new node
types to our graph which i'll go into
more detail on in the next slides
pii semantic type data subject type and
data storage security
so pia semantic type that is referring
to a set value that describes the
general contents of data in a column
with a focus on discovering data that
fits into one of three buckets
so the data could be sensitive by itself
could be sensitive when taken together
with other data
or could link to sensitive data like an
internal identification token
so the goal with this metadata isn't to
look at all the data that exists and
categorize it
it's only to categorize potentially
sensitive data so that we can better
understand
what it is for our privacy purposes so
this image shows
what the information looks like in our
graph database so we have the column
node
which gets links to the pi semantic type
and this can be shared between columns
that have the same type of data
and i'll give more examples in the next
slides
the next meditate metadata type we
introduced is data storage security so
this is a set value describing the form
of data in a column
um examples here could be plain text
encrypted redacted
um if we had a column that held the last
four digits of some sensitive
information
pii semantic type would describe the
type of data that that information is
and the data storage security value in
this case would be truncated since it's
only the last four digits
the last metadata type we introduced is
data subject type so this is a set value
that describes
users whose information exists in a
column
if we take the example from the last
slide some truncated sensitive data
we'd also want to understand what type
of user the data refers to
so we might have a product called test
product and the data subject type in
this case would be test product user
and just to clarify we expect that some
of the columns would have multiple pis
semantic types like let's say it's a
json blob
and multiple data subject types in some
cases so
the column in this example may actually
hold data for two different products
which would be stored as two separate
relationships between the column node
and two separate data subject types
in this example we have two columns that
hold data that's the same pii semantic
type
for the same type of user but in one
case the data is stored plain text and
in one case it's stored encrypted
with this setup with our graph database
we can write a simple query to uncover
the data that we deem to be less
protected
based on our risk model and make quick
changes as necessary
we also updated the ui so to show the
new metadata
in this example you can see that the
birthday column is actually tagged for
being a birth date
and that it refers to the specific date
of birth of
someone who is the some person data type
all right so let's talk about the work
we're doing to automate data inventory
this work takes place in the data
builder service inside of a munson
why would we want to automate data
inventorying well we have a lot of data
so at square we have hundreds of
thousands of table nodes and an order of
magnitude more column nodes
and we still face the tall challenge of
keeping our metadata about our data up
to date
and ensuring that information given to
us by data owners is correct over time
also data sources get created all the
time so
reducing the burden on our data owners
to properly annotate their tables when
they're created
it can lead to less work for them and
better metadata for us
um also mistakes happen so if a data
owner tells us that something's not
sensitive but the name of the column is
user phone number
we might want to take another look at
that um and so we can check the first
few rows of randomly named columns
or sorry we can check the first few rows
of data and see if
there's sensitive data that somebody has
missed
um and just to give a really rough
example so let's say we have a column
um and it has the data storage security
type of encrypted
but i'm a data owner and i know that
this recently changed so
i know we're actually storing this
information as truncated instead of
encrypted
um to reduce manual work and with future
scale in mind we actually introduced a
concept of
being able to flag a column if the
metadata is missing or incorrect
so flags are meant to highlight data
storage locations that we've judged as
likely to hold sensitive data
but they're possibly missing correct
metadata
so what's a flag a flag is also a new
node in our graph database
it contains information about the
metadata type it relates to which
it could be pii semantic type data
storage security data subject
type we also have some flags that are
general flags
um it also contains the possible values
so if this is a data storage security
flag the value might be it's encrypted
hey we think this value is encrypted
um and then it includes the human
readable description so we can display
that in our ui
um and then this is the this is one of
the benefits of using a graph database
here
we can store things like the reason
something was flagged or the result of
the flag was the flag actually accurate
and the person who reviewed this file on
that relationship between the two nodes
so when we're ingesting schema
information from our data sources we
actually run this information through
our first level of checks looking for
low-hanging fruit like looking for
things that we can flag
um so we ask questions like is the
column name an exact or partial keyword
match for a value we expect
we actually have a whole list of
keywords that we associate with various
pii semantic types
um so in this system if we have a column
called first name
that would be an exact match for a
person named keyword
um and then a column named account first
name or name would return a partial
keyword match so that would be like the
reason something is flagged
um we also asked does the column type
match what we expect so
a column named email status that would
trigger a partial keyword match for
email address the pii semantic type
but since the type of this value is a
boolean and we only expect a string for
an email address
we wouldn't flag it because we would
assume that a boolean value wouldn't
really be sensitive if it was referring
to an email address um we ask is the
column name literal pii
so there are some cases where in a rare
edge case
we're ingesting information from a
spreadsheet directly into a database and
it's technically possible
though it's an edge case that the column
names might be like the first row of the
spreadsheet so
we also have like a set of regexes that
we we use to
catch like basic examples um the last
thing we ask is is the table name an
exact or partial keyword match for the
value we expect
so we've already done checks on column
names but if the table is called phone
numbers
that sends a pretty good signal that the
data in the table might be sensitive
even if the columns are named something
random
um so we run a job that samples values
from the specific columns we're
interested in and it sends the actual
data to the google dlp api
if this api tells us that the values are
likely sensitive we flag the column this
is like an additional signal
and if not we tag the column with the
date that it was last checked
so we can wait before trying to throw it
against the google dlp api again
and we'll still flag the column based on
the answers to the questions we asked
earlier
but this check gives us additional
signal into whether something is
sensitive whether or not we answered yes
to a previous question
um all right so in this example we have
a column that has been flagged for two
different things
so one flag is for data storage security
we think that this value is stored plain
text
one flag is for pai semantic type for
some reason we think that it might be a
phone number
um one person reviews the first flag and
they say yeah it is in plain text
once they review the flag we
automatically set metadata
on this column um that aligns with what
the flag thought it was so in this case
we're setting a data storage security
node
directly on this column that shows that
it's plain text
another reviewer said for the second
flag they said like no
this is not a phone number so in that
case we'll resolve the flag
and we have logic to make sure that that
flag doesn't get created again
since somebody who we trust as being a
data owner has said that
that's not the case
all right so this is a screenshot from
our review page in square's version of
amansin
um this page actually doesn't exist in
the munzen master it's something that we
built out at square but
that we could contribute back in the
future um
here data owners can view flags on their
data and decide whether the flags are
correct or not so
not everyone will see the same results
on this page you only are going to see
flags for the data that you own
in the future we're adding support so
that non-data owners will be able to
flag columns that they believe
hold sensitive information like either
they don't have
the meta metadata values set or they
think the values are incorrect
and this will allow us to further reduce
the chances that our metadata
is incorrect for any amount of time
um we also display flag information to
data owners on the table detail page
so you can see here that a column named
phone number has been flagged
and i would only be able to see this
flag again if i was the data owner
and if i was to click yes this page
would actually refresh
and you could see here that the column
was tagged with the pii semantic type
for phone number
um if i clicked no instead this flag
would be resolved as being false
and the column wouldn't get flagged for
the same thing again
um well not the same thing for the same
reason at least we're continuing to
iterate on this logic so that we can
help our data owners better understand
their data
and supplement the annotation work that
they're doing manually um so with the
immense
ui for creating a centralized
transparent metadata store
trying to enable easy discoverability of
data and quick feedback loops for
maintaining
this privacy empowering metadata
all right so let's talk about how we're
working to support more granular access
controls
at square
um we're currently in the process as i
said of supporting more granular access
control based on the metadata we're
centralizing in a months in
so we've introduced this idea of
capability governed access control
we believe that access controls based on
this concept of capabilities are easier
to reason about and therefore easier to
follow and enforce
so to do this we created two additional
concepts within our graph database
and within the larger square community
purpose
which in this case would be an
enumerated legal approved reason to
access specific pii semantic types
and capability which would be a
combination of purpose which could
include multiple pi semantic types and
data subject type
so high level this is how it looks we
have a capability and it's sort of
encompassing this purpose and subject
type
as an example um let's say we have a
customer support specialist for cash app
and they might be granted a capability
that includes the purpose user support
so user support would include the pei
semantic types email address and person
name
so that grantees can properly
communicate with users who request
assistance on the app
the capabilities data subject type is
more specific in this case it would be
the cash app customer
so customer support specialists for two
different business units would have
separate capabilities even though they
would share the same purpose like in
that backend database
so because pi semantic types and data
subject types are tagged at the column
level
we can expose an endpoint within a
munson that will tell callers which
specific columns an employee has access
to
based on their capabilities so a service
in charge of getting access to snowflake
for example
we'd call the munson to get that list of
tables and columns and
it would actually build specific
snowflake views for the user that only
include the columns that they're allowed
to access
in the example i gave before if a
customer support specialist was only
granted access
to that one specific capability in the
databases they have access to they'd
only be able to access columns that have
specifically been marked as not pii
or columns that refer to cash app
customers that have been marked as
email address or person name it just
makes it like a lot more specific
um in the future our users will be able
to visit the amounts in ui and see
like which specific columns the
capability will grant them access to
and they can request the access that
they need data owners
will then have better transparency into
the exact data a user can access
and this will empower them to revoke
access that no longer seems relevant or
we could allow them to suggest a purpose
a new purpose if one seems unnecessarily
broad
okay so future work um
things that square is working on
currently we're in the process of
contributing back
the work we did on the gremlin proxy in
the metadata service for emunsin so
this will allow teams people who are
interested in working with the munson to
use databases like neptune and
januscraft for your back end
we're also doing a few things related to
the frontend ui so
we're building out ui components that
show users exactly what they have access
to based on their capabilities as i just
described
we're developing pages that show users
what a specific capability grants them
down to the column level
and then we're also building ui
components that empower data owners to
revoke broad access to some data
if they deem it unnecessarily available
we're also working to support additional
data types in our version of the months
and so
this would go alongside tables and
dashboards
this includes things like protocol
buffer definitions which will allow us
to better tie together
our data in flight with our data at rest
and we have lots of other ideas for how
we can build further on top of the
munson so
if you're interested in joining our team
reach out because we're definitely
hiring but then i'm going to pass it
over to mark to
give a little summary cool thank you
alyssa so to summarize
as you would see in the next slide we've
shown you examples of these two
applications that leverage
the same metadata and and what we wanted
to share is that
we believe the true power of metadata
comes when you can use the same metadata
to power multiple different applications
so can you be more compliant with gdpr
ccp or financial obligations can you
monitor your data manage the
data quality the cost or the maintenance
of evolution of data so on and so forth
and
that's where we see the true power come
in
and on the next slide um you would see
uh some links for you to get started so
there's a link to the amazon github page
uh the the link to join slack even
though it says link to join github it's
700 users in there uh the
there's a block from melissa which is uh
linked up there a monsoon for privacy at
square and then a bunch of blogs
around a month in the architecture
there's a youtube channel with
videos like this on there and uh
that would be all from from us today